NARRATOR:
Tonight, by popular demand,
it's a very special
young-entrepreneur episode
of "Shark Tank," where we look
to the future of America.
I may be young, but I can make
a difference in this world.
NARRATOR:
Millions of young Americans
are inspired by "Shark Tank,"
and many feel they can do
as well as the adults.
HERJAVEC: We treated you
just like we did anybody
at any age.
It's real money.
It's real serious.
Let me show you how it works.
NARRATOR: Tonight, we give them
a chance to pitch the sharks
in hopes of getting
an investment to start, grow,
or save their businesses.
It's not just for kids.
I'm in 300 stores in 34 states.
My parents have taken out
a mortgage.
D'oh.
NARRATOR:
They must convince a shark
to invest the full amount
they're asking for,
or they'll walk away
with nothing.
You have
serious competition.
$40,000 is
an absolute-nothing burger.
I immigrated to America
when I was 6 years old.
I was about to go to the U.S.
Open until I broke my back.
NARRATOR:
If the sharks hear a good idea,
they're ready to invest
using their own money.
What if we gave them 300k?
Are you nuts?
NARRATOR: And they're willing
to fight each other
for a piece of the action.
I'm the only shark that wants
to help the children.
Oh, my God.
He just wants
to be a vampire
that sucks the money
out of other businesses.
Mark, why don't you just stick
your head in that beehive?
GREINER: [laughs]
NARRATOR:
Who are the sharks?
They're self-made millionaire
and billionaire investors
who are entrepreneurs
themselves.
Kevin O'Leary
is a venture capitalist
who turned a $10,000 loan
into a software business
worth $4.2 billion.
Barbara Corcoran went
from waiting tables in Manhattan
to building the city's
preeminent real-estate empire.
Robert Herjavec, the son
of an immigrant factory worker,
is now a technology mogul
who sold his first internet
companies for over $350 million.
Lori Greiner, the queen of QVC,
holds over 100 patents and
has launched over 300 products,
grossing over a half a billion
dollars in retail sales.
And Mark Cuban,
notorious billionaire
entrepreneur, tech guru,
and the outspoken owner
of the NBA's Dallas Mavericks.
First into the tank
is an entrepreneur
with an easier
and more appealing way
to drink healthy beverages.
Hello, sharks.
My name is Carter Kostler.
I'm from Virginia Beach,
Virginia,
and my company
is the Define Bottle.
Today, I'm seeking $100,000
in exchange for 20% equity
in my company.
There is an epidemic of soda
in our refrigerators.
Everyone knows these
sugary drinks are bad for you,
yet the average American
continues to drink
one or two cans a day.
You should be grabbing a water,
but plain water
is just so boring.
If only there were
a simple and healthy way
to make water more exciting.
Oh, that's right, there is.
Introducing my product,
the Define Bottle,
a simple and beautiful way
to take fresh,
fruit-infused water to go.
Let me show you how it works.
First thing you're gonna do
is chop up
your freshly sliced fruit
of your choice.
Place it in the bottom chamber,
where there is a refreezable
base piece
that helps keep your fruit cool.
Add your strainer piece and your
top chamber and fill with water.
Notice, when I fill
the Define Bottle up with water,
the water goes down
into the bottom,
but the fruit does not rise
to the mouthpiece.
Add your lid, pop your top,
and you're ready to go.
After about 15 minutes,
the water will be infused
by the fruit,
adding a refreshing hint
of flavor.
Clever.
Now, sharks, I have
a Define Bottle
for each of you
filled
with your favorite fruit.
Okay.
There you go, Robert.
Thanks, Carter.
No problem.
And then, Kevin,
we got Mango.
Yes.
It's your favorite.
You didn't have any
with garlic?
Garlic?
For this guy.
CUBAN:
Garlic kills vampires.
Oh, wow,
that's great, Carter.
KOSTLER:
Congratulations.
You are doing something
to improve your health.
I may be young, but that does
not hold be back from knowing
that I can make a difference
in this world.
Now I'm looking for a partner
to help me transform
the way people hydrate.
So, sharks,
who wants to help the world
define what they drink?
So, Carter,
how young are you?
I am 15.
What?
15?!
Are you kidding?
You look at least 16.
CUBAN: You look a whole lot
older than 15, Carter.
Really? Well, thank you.
Absolutely.
Oh, my gosh.
Did you create this yourself?
Yeah, I created it
when I was 13 years old.
The story is my mom
got really into the whole
fruit-infused-water scene.
But whenever my mom
left the house,
she always grabbed soda
or a juice.
So, I wanted my mom
to enjoy those fresh,
fruit-infused water recipes
when she left the house.
So, I did some sketches
on a little legal pad,
and I pitched the idea
to my parents.
What are your sales?
We have done $65,000 in sales
since may 15th.
Wow.
In 4 months, $65,000?
Yes.
And was that at wholesale
or at retail?
Well, 50% of our sales
have been online.
50% have been wholesale.
We sold them on our website,
and we have retail accounts.
Who do you have
as retailers?
Whole Foods,
Davids Teas in Canada.
Carter, how did
Davids Tea find you?
How did Whole Foods
find you?
I cold-called companies,
so I walked into Whole Foods --
Like, right at the store?
Literally, right at the store --
walked in, said, "Hey, can I
speak to the produce manager?"
Shake his hand, looked him
in the eye, and I say,
"Sir, this product is gonna be
excellent at Whole Foods."
Love the hustle,
my friend.
Thank you.
We got invited to the whole
foods farmers' market,
and we did $1,000 worth
of bottles in 3 hours.
Tell me about
the Davids Tea order.
Is that a firm order?
Yes, we did a order of 165
bottles, and they all sold out.
They loved it.
Okay, and do -- do you have
a reorder from them?
We don't have a reorder yet.
Why?
It's -- it's too early, I think.
Carter, let me go back
for a second.
What do you sell it for
at retail,
and what does it
cost you?
The retail price
for that bottle is $30,
and it costs,
to get to our door, $10.
But we're currently talking
to a manufacturer over in China,
and they have guaranteed us
they can get the price
of this bottle down to $5.
CUBAN:
What about online?
Where's your traffic coming
from online?
Right, yeah, absolutely.
Well, early on,
I created fruit-infused-water
recipe websites.
And my goal was to promote the
Define Bottle on those sites.
Okay. What kind of traffic
are you getting,
what kind of conversion
and what do you know
about your customers?
Okay, well, we currently get
2,000 hits a day on those sites.
Okay.
And our conversion rate,
I think it's 0.5.
Why do you think your
conversion rate's so low?
You know, I don't know.
I have a question, Mark,
that might answer some of this.
Yes.
Are you aware of your
competition out there?
Yes.
Our biggest competitor,
they're currently selling
in Brookstone.
It's big. It's bulky.
It's stainless steel.
You can't see the fruit like
in the Define Bottle you can.
And it has little razor blades
on the bottom
that require you to mash up
and grind up your fruit.
The problem is, while it's
very nice and it works well,
there's a ton of competition
out in the space right now
with this exact same
kind of thing.
And they're a lot
less expensive,
but I think
they also work well.
For that reason,
I'm out.
Okay. Thank you.
How much have you spent
developing it?
$300,000.
Wow.
You've got to be kidding.
My parents have taken out
a mortgage on the house.
D'oh.
Wow. This is a big bet
you guys have made.
I think your product's
so darn pretty,
I want to own one.
But $300,000 for your parents
blows my mind.
Carter, I think you spent
way too much money
developing this.
I'd never get my money back.
I'm out.
Okay.
Well, thank you.
O'LEARY:
So, there's a tremendous amount
of competition.
And in my view,
it's not investable.
For that reason, I'm out.
Okay.
Two sharks left on either end.
HERJAVEC: Carter,
here's where I'm at.
This is a beautiful,
beautiful design.
You've got
some great retailers.
So, that's all good news.
Here's the bad news.
You're into a retailer
that gave you a great order,
and they didn't reorder.
And you don't know why.
But I like the product.
Thank you.
We need to do
some research,
but I'm willing
to make you an offer.
NARRATOR:
Three sharks are out,
but Robert is willing
to take a chance.
I'm willing
to make you an offer.
I'll give you the $100,000
that you're looking for,
but because there's risk,
I want 40% of the business.
Okay.
Um...Robert, thank you
so much for your offer.
Uh, would you mind
if I go in the hallway
and talk to my parents?
Well,
there's another shark.
Don't you want to hear what --
No, go ahead. no, go ahead.
Talk to your parents.
Don't you want to find out
what Mr. Cuban's doing?
No, I want him to talk
to his parents first.
[laughs]
Okay, thank you.
Lori, Barbara...
Uh-huh.
...And Kevin are out.
Robert is asking for 40%.
Have you told them
what assets you have yet?
No, I have not.
It didn't come up yet.
Should he ask more
to help us out?
Oh, well, then,
you need to do that.
That's my opinion that you need
to go back and say...
They didn't ask.
..."Here's what my --
and here's what
the company is worth."
Mark,
what are you thinking?
At 15,
when I had my businesses,
I could walk into anywhere.
No one's gonna say no.
Everybody's always gonna
give you a chance.
Right, no one's gonna be
mean to a kid.
So, there's a balance between
what's real and sustainable
by the product itself
and what's just the carry
of him being a kid.
But I don't know that.
But that said,
it's a cool product.
Carter, welcome back.
So, the offer was $100,000
for 40%.
Right. My parents and I
discussed it out there,
and we think that our company is
worth a little more than that.
We -- we have assets.
We have $85,000 in tooling,
150 grand in inventory.
We have sales of $65,000
since May 15th,
projected sales of $200,000
this year,
$400,000 in sales next year.
Carter, what do you think
it's worth?
Uh, $500,000.
So, you are not going to take
his offer of $100,000 for 40%.
That's what I hear.
Well, Robert, would you
be willing to do 30%?
It's like I said.
We have assets.
Carter, the assets
are only worth something
if the company
is successful.
It's not like
if you stumble,
we can sell the assets
for something else.
I appreciate
where you're coming from,
but I'm not gonna take
your counteroffer
because I think there's
a tremendous amount of risk
that all the other sharks
have brought up.
I can't get to the valuation
that you have
and marry it
against that risk.
I'm out.
Okay. Thank you.
I'm trying to find reasons
to say yes, Carter.
But the fact
that your parents
took out a mortgage
to support this --
that just puts so much stress
on the whole thing,
and you didn't give me enough
depth on your competition
to have any type
of confidence
that the competition
isn't just going
to dominate this market.
And for that reason,
I have to say I'm out.
Okay.
You did a great job in here,
though, presenting yourself.
Thank you.
We treated you just like we did
anybody at any age.
You should be
very proud of that.
Thank you all so much.
Good luck, Carter.
I think it's remarkable
that he was 15 years old.
Remarkable.
Hey.
MOM: How'd it go?
Not well.
We didn't get a deal.
KOSTLER: You know,
the future is very bright.
Our sales are going up and up,
and even though this might be
a little setback,
we're just gonna move on
and keep rolling.
NARRATOR: Last season,
we saw 11-year-old Ryan Kelly
and his mom, Daniela,
make a deal with Barbara
for his homemade-dog-treats
company, Ryan's Barkery.
Have you sold
any of these?
We've sold
about 200 bags of them.
I'd love to make you
a full-price offer.
We have a deal.
Aah!
Yeah, there you go!
MAN: All right.
NARRATOR: Let's see
what they're up to now.
RYAN: Barbara really made
a lot of things happen
for Ryan's Barkery.
She helped us get
into stew Leonard's,
and it feels like a dream.
Hey, everybody!
Ryan!
Hi!
CORCORAN: Stew Leonard's is
a landmark in the local area,
and most importantly,
they have customers.
And that's why we're here.
You want pumpkin-apple?
I feel super-excited
about my business.
I have a new logo and a great,
new, professional packaging.
And it looks amazing.
Before "Shark Tank,"
I made about $900,
and in 5 months,
I've made over $70,000.
So, first,
you need a shirt.
Ryan has a new sales strategy.
Go start selling.
He's recruiting other kids
to sell his dog biscuits
in their local town,
their local neighborhood,
and to their lacrosse team.
Ha!
[whistle blows]
Who's got a dog?
You got a dog?
You want to see a picture?
No, we want to sell you
some dog food.
Oh.
Watching Ryan go through
this "Shark Tank" experience --
it's been wonderful
to watch him grow into
what he's really capable of.
So, how much
did we make?
ALL: $1,019.
Oh, my!
I feel that Barbara
invested in me
because she sees a lot
of potential in the business.
And I think she's right.
NARRATOR:
Next up is a student
who hopes to save the planet
from electronic waste.
Hi. My name is Jason, and
I'm the proud owner of iReTron.
Today, I'm seeking $100,000 in
exchange for 20% of my company.
As a social enterprise,
iReTron is an online,
recommerce business
that buys used
or unwanted electronics.
Not only do we offer
the highest price on the market,
but we are also
the greenest place for you
to get rid of your cellphones,
calculators,
MP3 players, and more.
Now, sharks,
I know you guys always want
the biggest, baddest, newest,
smartest smartphones
there is to offer.
However, not everyone
is that case.
In fact me, myself, I don't
even want the newest model.
And thus, iReTron caters to them
by providing older phones
that still have years of life
left in them
to people who can't pay the
full price for their technology.
The best part is it's as easy
as, one, go on our website
and receive an instant quote,
and number two, ship us
your product free of charge.
And finally, 3, get paid
in less than 48 hours.
It's green for the world.
It's green for your wallet.
What do you say, sharks?
Time for you to retron.
Walk me
through an example.
I sell you my old phone.
Right.
Do you fix it up then
and try to sell it
to somebody else?
We'll inspect it
within 48 hours,
then we'll send you a check.
Okay.
So, your part is done.
Do you have a guaranteed buyer
on your end?
Yes.
And that's been proven
because we've been running this
for two years,
and we have zero inventory,
meaning that it never
gets stuck.
All right, selling it
is so much easier
than actually getting
the product,
and that's what we need
to work on.
We need to market
because I haven't spent any
money yet on advertisements.
Jason,
what makes you different
from the other 90 guys
doing this?
Doing the exact same thing.
LI: Right.
Um, so, yes, I am aware that
we do have a lot of competition,
but the one thing
that separates us
is that
we're a social enterprise.
If you look at our website,
we accept over 5,000
different products,
including products
that have literally no value
because, number one,
it's environmentally friendly,
and, number two, it's a simple
way of customer acquisition.
So, you're basically
telling me
you're making less for me
as an investor
because you're buying stuff
that nobody wants,
so that costs me.
You're paying higher prices,
which kills my margins.
Everybody's telling me they're
green because that's for free.
Anybody can say that.
Mm-hmm.
But there's so much competition.
In fact, if you Google this,
there's so many pages,
you'll die of old age
getting to the last.
But if you Google us right now,
if you search, "sell my Kindle,"
we're actually on the first page
of Google.
All right, Jason.
Let's forget what Kevin says.
Let's see what the market says.
What are your sales?
So, in the past 12 months,
we made $40,000.
And I don't want you guys
to get caught up in the numbers
because --
Why not?
Because you have to look
at our growth rate first.
Our first --
$40,000 in this industry
is an absolute-nothing burger.
On that $40,000 that you made
in profit, how much --
LI: $10,000.
So, we have about
a 25% net-profit margin.
Jason,
do you do this full-time?
No. I'm 16 years old.
I'm a senior in high --
Oh, you're only 16?
You're 16?
Wow.
Yeah.
Look at the size of you.
Wow. I thought
you were in college.
I thought you were,
like, 25.
Oh, no, no, no.
CUBAN: Freshman.
Oh, yeah.
You look very mature.
LI: Thank you.
So, I have a question.
Now we have to be
nicer to you.
You're obviously very savvy.
You know what's out there.
What do you think you have
to offer that's better?
Um, well, the one thing
that separates us --
you know, we're not always,
you know, 100% profit-driven.
We care about social,
environment,
and profit all equally.
Jason, what drives you?
Is it
the social responsibility,
or are you -- are you trying
to build a business?
I think there was --
there's a lot of things.
Um, I immigrated to America
when I was 6 years old.
Where'd you come from?
China.
I always wanted to be
independent,
and I always wanted
to contribute
rather than to take for myself.
I like to say that had
two passions in my life.
One is judo,
and the other is iReTron.
And so, with judo, I started
that when I was 5 years old,
and I wasn't half bad, either.
I got to nationals.
That's great.
And I was about to go
to the U.S. Open
until, um, I broke my back.
[gasps] Wow.
And in the month
that I was in bed resting,
I began reading a lot of books,
and one of them was called
"How to Change the World"
by David Bornstein...
Mm.
...In which he talks about
social entrepreneurship
in third-world countries
and how that's really
making a difference.
Jason, I just read
in the "Wall Street Journal"
that something like 85%
of all new businesses
are started by immigrants
or children of immigrants.
I admire how far
you've come at 16
because, my friend, at 16,
I wasn't anywhere near
where you are right now.
Thank you so much.
The business you presented
today -- I'm not seeing it.
And to give you $100,000 --
I just don't think I see
how it's gonna make
the business better.
I wish you all the best,
but I'm out.
Thank you.
Look, when I was 16,
I wasn't doing electronics,
but I was buying
and selling stamps.
I already knew
what I could sell it for...
Mm-hmm.
...So I could flip it
very quickly.
Exactly what this is.
That's exactly
what this is.
Right.
But the point is right now
you're forced to hustle.
Everything is,
"I've got to go out there
and figure out how to pay for it
before I do it."
Uh-huh.
Right?
Introducing that much capital
into a business,
it gives you a comfort level
that you shouldn't have,
particularly while
you're still in school.
I mean,
I love what you're doing,
but it scares me
that the money would take you
in a different direction.
And so, for that reason,
I'm out.
Well, thank you very much
for your time.
And really, part of this
is all about inspiring
the next generation.
[chuckling] Jason, you got
to deal with your generation
Before you worry
about the next generation.
Exactly.
No, and that's the thing.
I was thinking, "You know what?
"Next generation,
next generation --
that's my generation."
So, it's up to me
to make a solution.
And it's up to me
to inspire all of my friends
and all of my peers.
Jason, you valued this
at $500,000, okay?
Yes.
So, one test that you should
always do in your own mind
before you come in front
of an investor like me is,
"Could I do this myself
and own 100% of it
for a lot less than $500,000?"
Because there's nothing
proprietary
about what you're doing.
So, you've failed that test,
and, for that reason, I'm out.
All right, well, thank you
very much for your time.
CORCORAN: Hallelujah,
I can speak. Okay.
I'm not sure about this
business, all right?
I don't know if it's gonna win
or it's gonna lose.
So, it's a big question Mark,
quite honestly, in my head.
But what I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna offer you $100,000
for the 20% in your business
for one reason only.
I feel like
you're a winner.
I don't know what form
that winning's gonna take,
all right, but it comes
with a big contingency.
The contingency is --
well, twofold --
one, you're gonna get the money
on an as-needed basis
'cause you're only 16.
[laughs]
You talk like you're 30,
but you're only 16.
The other contingency is
I want to have 20% of any
business you think about
and start
over the next five years.
That is the kind of greed
that just disgusts me.
I'm putting a big, blank
check in on you,
which makes no sense,
but I can't help but to feel
you are a winner.
Wow.
Thank you. Um...
Well,
I think you're great.
I love what you're doing
because you're
a young entrepreneur.
I think that Barbara
has offered you a deal,
and it's a lot better
than what I would have offered,
so, for that reason,
I'll go out.
All right.
Well, thank you very much
for your time.
So, Barbara, I love your offer,
but if I can address Mark?
No problem at all.
Thank you.
She knows I'm not gonna try
to steal off that.
Thank you very much.
And so, Mark, look, honestly,
I'm not gonna stop hustling.
I've been working on this
for the past two years,
and I'm reaching a level
where I-I can't do any more
than what I can right now,
as in, like, I don't have
the ability or the knowledge.
And I really love the both of
you, and I would really love it
if both of you can -- you know,
if I could work
with both of you.
Would you guys like to come in
on this together?
I'll tell you this.
I'll tell you.
You do this deal
with Barbara.
I'll be a partner
with Barbara in it.
I-I'll split it.
I'll split it with you.
Yeah, I'll take money
from you. Why not?
You'll split it?
Yeah.
Um, let's do work.
Hey.
There you go.
"Let's do work."
I like it.
HERJAVEC: Wow.
You're gonna make me
do work.
GREINER: Good one.
Congratulations, Jason, man.
Thank you so much.
You made yourself
a good deal.
Thank you.
Nicely done.
[laughs]
Jason, you just proved
the American dream
is alive and well.
I'm trying to -- doing my best.
Good luck.
I like that.
"Doing work."
Thank you.
I could use your help.
I can't believe I just
shook hands with Mark Cuban.
I can't believe I just --
oh, yeah.
NARRATOR: Next into the tank
is a 6-year-old
with a product she invented
with some help from her dad.
Hi, sharks.
I'm Kiowa Grace Kavovit.
And I'm her dad,
Andrew Kavovit,
and we are here seeking
an investment of $100,000...
As well as your relationships
and ideas...
In exchange for 17.5% of
our company, boo boo brands.
So, please check out
this video we made
to help boo boo goo
come to life for you.
As an active 6-year-old,
cuts and scrapes
are just a part of life.
But not all boo-boos
are created equal.
And how am I supposed to
keep doing what kids do
if every little boo-boo
requires this?
[dramatic tones play]
Besides,
those sticky things hurt,
and they always come off
when I want them to stay on.
It's time kids think differently
about the world,
and I'm starting by cleaning up
one little boo-boo at a time.
So, I created this
one-of-a-kind, paint-on bandage.
Now, if I get a small cut
or boo-boo, I just clean it,
dry it, pick my color,
and paint it on.
Huh.
And it's waterproof.
Thanks, Mom.
And for those big nights out,
I choose the skin color to
conceal my boo-boos completely.
Let's go, Daddy.
Bye-bye, boo-boos,
and bye-bye, drama.
So, sharks, as you see,
BooBoo Goo is a playful
and less-intimidating way
to deal with boo-boos.
But make no mistake -- while
our product is kid-friendly...
It's not just for kids.
Our patent-pending formula
was actually developed
by a team of leading
wound-care chemists.
And me and my friends love
that it comes in a bunch
of fun colors and skin tones.
So, you can seal it...
And conceal it.
So, who wants
to come help the world
and clean up one boo-boo
at a time?
Thank you, sharks.
We have some samples here
that Kiowa
would like to hand out.
And if you have any questions,
we'd be happy to answer them.
We made
some special colors.
There's a skin tone
for you, Robert.
Thank you.
We have pink for you,
Lori.
Thank you, Kiowa.
Mr. Wonderful,
your favorite green.
Uh-huh.
Thank you.
You did great.
Barbara, we have another
skin tone for you.
Thank you.
And we made a Maverick blue
for you, Mr. Cuban.
How did you come up
with the idea?
I never liked band-aids,
and I didn't want people
ohh.
To see that I had something
'cause look at the board.
There's boo boo goo,
there's the other
paint-on bandage,
and there's the band-aid.
Hmm.
Which one
do you like best?
GREINER:
Great, little sales lady.
Yeah.
Who's your favorite shark,
by the way?
Go ahead.
You can say.
HERJAVEC: All the sharks
are her favorite.
Who? Kevin?
Mr. Wonderful?
I like all of you.
ALL: Ah.
Oh, political.
You saw where she pointed.
She's gonna be
a politician one day.
These are prototypes.
ANDREW: Correct.
Prototype bottles,
if I can clarify.
Prototype bottles.
The formula
is actually finalized.
As I mentioned,
it's been developed
by a leading team
of wound-care chemists.
They broke through
with a completely novel
and unique formulation.
What made it unique?
What was -- what was special
about the formulation?
The most special thing
is our actual sealant.
It's what makes it
waterproof.
Do you have a patent on it?
The patent is pending, um,
and we're gonna continue
to evolve that patent as
they strengthen the technology.
Is it something natural?
It is something natural.
What's left on the skin
at the end of the day
is a completely natural
and organic, pliable,
skin-like,
waterproof barrier.
You have
serious competition.
The major brands make
a spray-on type of product
that's very similar.
Yeah.
It's a liquid bandage.
Yours is colored...
Mm-hmm.
...But I don't think
I'm grasping
what is your
major advantage
or why you would be able
to take over the market?
We think it's very clear
that a person would not want
a scabbed wound showing,
which is all the liquid
bandages service now.
Also, all the liquid-bandages
formulations
on the market currently
are actually flammable.
They're found
in the medical aisle,
not in the band-aid aisle.
So, they have not
crossed over
to any kind
of mainstream market
and certainly haven't tapped
into the 70%
of bandage users,
which is kids
3 to 15 years old.
How are you gonna create
an identity in that market?
With the right partners.
We have interest already
from QVC.
Lori, is this a product
we can sell on QVC?
You know, I don't personally
see this as a QVC product.
O'LEARY: I think the problem
with your deal
that the sharks
have identified,
and I'm certainly
in this camp now,
is for you to get
any significant share in retail,
it's a very, very difficult,
uphill battle.
So, is there an opportunity
to take this
and go
to the majors and say,
"I have a better mouse trap
in the liquid-band-aid space.
"Look at the colors.
It's a better product.
License it from me."
That's exactly
the intention.
Look, this isn't
a small-camp thing.
This is a big product
in a billion-dollar category.
The fact is we need people
like you on the team.
Kiowa, do you know
what earmuffs are?
Do the earmuffs.
CORCORAN: Aw.
Aw, come on, Mark.
GREINER: Aw.
What do you got, Mark?
She can take it.
She can take it?
Okay.
CORCORAN: Come on.
Look, the liquid bandages,
for the most part,
are geared towards adults.
I've got three young kids,
and they're gonna still see
the scab or the wound, right,
and they're still gonna
pick at it, right?
Second, trying
to get this stuff off --
That's exactly the point,
Mark.
You put our product on
in the morning.
You don't reapply it.
There will be no chase
another band-aid down.
There's no falling it off
in the pool
when it's disgusting.
It's still a lot
of high-dollar players
that you're gonna be
competing with.
And you have to go through
the re-education process.
That re-education process
can't just be putting
the product on the shelf.
And so, for that reason,
I'm out.
Fair enough.
Thank you.
First off,
it's very painful for me
to watch you
go down this path.
I don't think there's a need
for this product -- period.
This is band-aids
that kids love picking at.
Whether they do
a good job or not,
parents love sticking them
on the kids' legs.
For those reasons, I'm out.
Andrew, they already have
a liquid bandage.
I think the fact that there's
color to a liquid bandage --
'cause we use them --
is interesting.
But I think, today,
what you haven't proven
is that that's unique enough
to be sold.
And you haven't proven
it'll sell.
Just too early
and not enough data today.
I'm out.
Fair enough.
Thank you, Robert.
I like that you created --
you added the color to it.
I mean, it's inventive.
But I think
there's too much competition.
I hope you do get your patent,
and I wish you good luck.
Without having it,
I feel that you're gonna
really have a struggle.
But you're beautiful, little
daughter is an inventor.
Yeah.
And that's fantastic.
You're thinking of things.
Keep thinking.
You're so young right now
that you could set the world on
fire with more and more ideas.
It only takes one
to become successful.
So, I'm out.
Thank you.
Mr. Wonderful.
Um, I'm stuck on the,
um, distribution strategy
without a patent.
If I really believe the patent
was gonna clear and be issued,
and I could go --
and I'd be good at this --
to a major and license it
to them,
I'd be a great partner for you.
But it's not investable
till you tell me
that you have a patent.
You came here without one.
I like it.
I think it could capture
some share
of the $200 million market.
And that's a growing market,
I think.
It will, and we'll make the
100 grand back on QVC alone.
I actually know
how to defend patents.
I have a lot
of lawyers on stun.
And we believe
it's a licensing deal.
He's a patent troll.
I am.
I'm proud to be one, and
it's what makes America great.
No, it makes --
It's killing us.
We don't agree,
but I'm right as usual.
Killing us.
We believe that this
is a licensing play.
Yeah, no.
We need the leadership
to take it there.
I-I-I get that.
Let's work something out.
All right.
If you want to do a deal
for a contingency
on getting the patent,
I'll invest the $100,000.
I want 25%.
HERJAVEC:
Contingent on the patent.
Contingent
on the patent clearing.
It has to be.
It has to be contingent
on the patent.
That's a reasonable
request.
It's the value that
we're expecting from this.
What do you think?
Yeah?
[laughs]
We appreciate it.
We would love
to take your offer.
You got it.
Wow.
Jump down, buddy.
Thank you.
Appreciate it.
And I'll show you.
All right.
We'll follow through
on this.
Good invention.
Thank you.
Yeah, right?
She's got more coming.
Thanks.
Good job, Kiowa.
You bet.
Thank you, everybody.
Bye-bye.
HERJAVEC: Good job, guys.
Nice meeting you all.
GREINER: Bye.
Good luck.
What do you say, girl?
Good job.
I'm the only shark
that wants to help the children.
Oh, my God.
CORCORAN: Yeah, sure.
KIOWA:
I'm really excited,
and I'm just happy
that we got a deal.
My name is Henry Miller.
I am 16 years old,
and I live on my family farm
in Deming, Washington.
I've learned a lot
about running my business
by being on the farm.
I've built fences,
cleaned up after the animals,
and I feed them.
And sometimes, you just got
to put a little bit
of elbow grease into it.
I really like bees
because they get so much hate
from a lot of people.
Bees all around the world
are suffering from
colony collapse disorder.
Colony collapse disorder
is a mysterious disease
that will infect the hive,
and it's very hard
to find the exact cause.
I started this company
to help save the bees
and my family farm.
My mom calls me
an eco-entrepreneur.
There's nothing
like my product in stores.
I created a new category
for honey to be in
that could change the world.
If we don't get an investment
from the sharks,
I feel that we may lose
our farm.
My mom and dad
have been funneling money
out of their retirement fund
and putting it
into the business,
and I feel like it's my job
to make this business
succeed for them.
CORCORAN:
I hope there's no bees.
[gasps]
Ooh.
Creepy.
Oh, wow.
Hi, sharks.
[laughs]
CUBAN: [laughs]
My name is Henry Miller.
I'm from Deming, Washington,
and I'm seeking $150,000
for a 25% stake of my incredible
company, Henry's Humdingers,
the natural condiment,
honey with a kick.
It all started back
when I was 11 years old,
and I sat next to a beekeeper
on a plane.
And I learned about
colony collapse disorder.
Did you know that if all the
bees died, within seven years,
the whole food chain
would collapse?
The unthinkable would happen.
Mr. Wonderful, you wouldn't be
able to make any more money.
Don't worry.
I speak bee.
[laughter]
Anyhow, I asked my parents for
a beehive for my 12th birthday,
and what do you know?
They got me one.
Next thing you know,
I had so much sweet honey,
I didn't know
what to do with it.
So, I started selling it
on the side of the road.
And I realized
I need to be different.
There's so many people out there
selling sweet honey
that it just needed to change.
And that's how
Henry's Humdingers was born.
And I turned beekeeping
into a business.
And I went from...
[Southern accent]
Henry's Humdingers...
[laughter]
[normal voice]
...To Henry's Humdingers LLC.
I take this ancient thing
like honey,
and I flip it upside down
by adding spices to it.
It's good in meatloaf,
over chicken, ice cream,
and even martinis --
so I've been told.
I brought some samples
for you all to try.
Thanks, Henry.
No problem.
I love the names.
Yep, I currently
have four flavors.
There's Grumpy Grandpa,
Naughty Nana,
Phoebe's Fireball,
and Diabolical Dad.
Henry, the Diabolical Dad
is fantastic.
Naughty Nana is, like --
We've made a cheesecake
out of that.
Wow.
Are there other
flavored honeys out there?
There are other
sweet-flavored honeys,
but I have not encountered
another spicy-flavored honey.
Where are you selling?
What retailers are you
in right now?
Right now, I'm in 300-plus
stores in 34 states,
and I'm in big distributors,
such as unify east.
Wow.
And I was in unify west.
What are your sales?
My sales -- in the past three
years that I've been --
been in business, I had $67,000.
$67,000?
Yeah.
What about
the last 12 months, Henry?
Probably about $50,000, I think.
Henry, you've been at this
for three years.
You're in 300 stores.
$50,000
in the past 12 months.
Don't you think
they should be higher
given the amount of time
you've put into it?
The main problem is
I don't have the capital.
That's why I'm here.
Got it.
HERJAVEC: Tell me about
the business today.
Who's running
this business?
I mean, obviously,
you didn't drop out of school.
My mom and dad are both working
at it while I'm at school.
I make a lot
of the executive decisions.
My mom's working full-time.
She gets paid in love
and teenaged angst.
Did you mention
how much money
your parents
put in the business?
I'm sorry.
I don't think I --
They have put $150,000.
One of my good friends
is the largest honey provider
in Canada.
It's a massive operation.
He's already got
the distribution and so on.
How do you compete
with something like that?
People who have those
large-scale honey things,
they don't want to have to go in
and clean all of our spices out
every time
so they can do
their clean honey run.
So, just so I'm clear,
I can't go to
an existing honey company
and add spices to it.
It would be very expensive.
But, Henry,
is there a possibility
the reason that none of the big
honey guys have done this
is the market is actually
very small for spiced honey?
We need more, like,
consumer education.
That's what a lot of this
will go towards
because people need to know
what it is.
It's not a sweetener.
It's a condiment.
So, you want me to help educate
America about spices
and garlic in honey when maybe
they don't want to know.
See, the thing about Kevin --
He has no concept
of opening up a new category
and creating a new business.
He just wants to be
a vampire
that sucks the money
out of other businesses.
You know, you can say that,
but the truth is,
I think I'm right.
I don't think people want,
in a large scale,
to buy honey with garlic in it
or honey with jalapeo peppers
in it.
Then just go out.
Do you have
your own website?
MILLER: Yes.
Are you doing any type
of marketing
to drive people
to your website?
I go to food shows
a lot of the time.
My first food show I went to
was national expo west.
I went there, and afterwards
Wegmans called me.
Are you in Wegmans?
Yeah, I -- Wegmans has reordered
three times now.
O'LEARY: So, Henry,
I look at it this way.
This is a very small category,
so if this takes off,
the big honey guys
can also add spices to honey.
They already have
the shelf space,
and they'll crush you
like the bee you are.
Unfortunately, for you,
I'm the only shark that tells
the truth all of the time.
You're about to hear everybody
give you lots of encouragement,
but I don't think they're gonna
write you a check for $150,000.
I'm out.
All right. Thank you.
What a nice guy.
What's wrong
with encouragement?
If you're encouraging him
to pursue something
that will never make him money,
you're actually the devil.
[laughs] We all know
where you're from.
Hey, I tell the truth.
I am the angel on his shoulder.
I think it's great
that you are enterprising,
that you are caring about bees
and our ecology.
But my personal opinion is
it's very difficult
to sell something spicy
like this with honey
when I think most people
probably do like
just plain honey.
Mm.
So, my opinion is
this will be a hard --
a hard trek.
I'm not sure I would get
back the $150,000,
and so, for that reason,
I'm out.
Okay.
Thank you for listening.
Well, I find you
so adorable, Henry.
You're almost irresistible.
I think people are gonna
fall for you,
and I think you shouldn't
get a partner here.
I think you should go
and do some crowdfunding.
You do your pitch online,
you're gonna get all the money
you need.
I'm out because I think
you have a long road,
but I don't think
you need me,
and I don't think
you need anybody here.
Let me tell you
where I'm at.
I mean, gosh, if there's a
business I know a lot about --
I wish you, me, and my friend
could sit in a room
'cause I'm fascinated
by this product.
Robert, before you go out,
let me throw something by you.
NARRATOR:
Three sharks are out,
but Henry has two more chances
to make a deal.
HERJAVEC: Let me tell you
where I'm at.
I mean, gosh, if there's a
business I know a lot about --
I wish you, me, and my friend
could sit in a room
'cause I'm fascinated
by this product.
Robert, before you go out,
let me throw something by you.
Since you know this business,
all right,
what if we upped the amount
and took majority ownership
and took it over
and let him retain equity?
Are you nuts?
All right, what amount?
What if we gave them 300k
for 60%?
And I've never, ever --
in every deal
I've ever done
on "Shark Tank"
even offered
to take a majority.
To me,
that's always a negative.
But in this --
So, why is this different?
This is different because
you're creating a category,
and you need pros
who are going to come in
and fight the battle.
We take that 300k.
That way, you can take the 150k,
pay back your parents.
Mark, why don't you just stick
your head in that beehive?
It's easier.
Yeah.
[laughs]
You know, Kevin,
that's the thing.
That's the difference
between us, Kevin.
I see an idea,
I see an opportunity,
and I can see the endgame
and how it can be enormous.
HERJAVEC: Mark,
it's an interesting angle,
but I don't think your pricing
enough of the risk at 60%.
Let's do the $300,000
for 75%.
Now who's the vampire?
This could be
something big.
$300,000 for 75%.
$150,000 each
from Mark and I.
[sighs]
There's no way
you would consider
anything less
than majority share?
T-the thing about it is
we want the ability to just
take this and run with it.
I get that.
One of the challenges
in "Shark Tank"
is we invest in companies --
at least, that I've learned
over the years,
is when it's family-run,
there's a lot
of unique dynamics.
And it's very difficult
to just say, "Go, go, go,"
which is what you want when
you've just invested $150,000
and you see
the opportunity.
You're still a kid, but
let me tell you something.
When we get this serious
about it, money sees no age.
It's real money.
It's real serious.
Henry, it's your business,
so this is a serious thing.
It's a big thing.
I-if you want to make
a phone call --
MILLER:
I'm not gonna consult my parents
because they told me,
"This is your company.
"Even though it's our money,
you started this thing.
This is your baby."
Look, Henry, I don't want
to sugar-coat this
and try to talk you
into anything.
I want to be brutally honest
on this, right?
Because it's
a new category --
It's really hard
to start new categories.
1,000 nos.
If you want to go into it
and own it
and develop this yourself,
absolutely,
if that's the dream
and that's the goal,
then that's exactly
what you should stick to,
and you should say no.
And so, I don't -- I'm not
here to talk you into it.
I'm here to give you
an alternative.
Henry, $300,000 for 75%
from Mark and I.
What would you like
to do?
If I may, I think I'm going to
consult the bees on this one.
[laughter]
[bees buzzing]
I think they said yes.
There you go.
All right.
HERJAVEC: Very interesting.
Congrats, man.
Oh, thank you.
It'll be awesome.
Well done there.
Thank you so much.
Well thought out.
We'll make it all work.
Yeah.
Thank you.
GREINER: Good luck.
Whoo!
Um, Robert and Mark
both went in,
and they -- they offered
$300,000 for 75%.
To pay my parents back
just means the world to me.
They have just believed in me.
Like, who invests $150,000
into a 12-year-old at the time?
Like, seriously, who does that?
Crazy people.
$150,000 of that 300k
is gonna go straight back
to refunding you guys.
I really think
it's a great deal.
[sniffles]
[crying] Honey.
Was that a pun?
[laughs]